[Musique]
deux femmes étudiées changer
gouvernement les mutations
technologiques
nous sommes des pompiers de la
transformation digitale et c'est
formidable je veux partager avec vous
cette problématique de relever la
révolution digitale locaux
ruffier objet la pratique de l'histoire
de poubelle s'est en fait
l'ancêtre de la calculatrice donc la 7e
et la paix
g
je possède 400 ha ha d'un doublé et les
ennuis de santé
alors c'est la merde jusqu'au cou r cela
majid
il ya deux cents ans et la bise à la
mère sauf wet look sombre bilan de la
région écolo et le ps c'est la qualité
audio numérique mais le reste de
l'humanité
je crois que ce soir la coupe d'affilée
sans aux règles de la fiducie du
vaisseau oui nous les appliquer dans
notre sens notre poupe
nous l'avons notre ami
eu de voix
des pouvoirs révolution historique
jusqu'à le jeu il y en a quatre
la première révolution industrielle qui
a vu les indices est aux assassins cette
révolution se poursuivre tout et la
découverte de synergies nouvelles qui
téléchargent
c'est autour de cette révolution on a
inventé la machine à vapeur et bien phu
à qui des soins qu'à arrêter la machine
à vapeur tout des attributions des
machines inventées dans le domaine de
l'industrie et de la sidérurgie un
viseur de solutions industrielles a eu
lieu en 10 70 c'est une révolution qui
sont conçus pour tous il avait des
nouvelles sur nrj et l électricité le
pétrole le gave au coût de cette
révolution
il a été développé de communier la chine
et les machines-outils la troisième
révolution industrielle
encore appelée révolution du transport
et la coordination qui vont accélérer au
fait des échanges commerciaux
rexel a retenu la révolte la révolution
source de la mondialisation au coude et
f2
nous allons convaincre l'essonne rec
développement en série de la voiture
notamment une fois l'iss et la naissance
de l'avion cette révolution aussi va
connaître les inventions majeures
notamment le téléphone à abbey et le
télégramme qui vont révolutionner et
finalement aujourd'hui la 4ème de
pollution industrielle pour l'un puisse
plus ou encore révolution digitale qui a
lieu sous nos yeux avec l'apparition
d'internet
cette révolution quatrième c'est la
première révolution n'est pas prendre
racine dans l'émergence d'une nouvelle
source d'énergie
la source de cette révolution et menthe
ou contiennent en fait d'un nouveau
phénomène technologie qui est la
numérisation
cette numérisation permet l'édification
des magnifiques apathie vite et on peut
piloter tous les objets physiques
en fait c'est les films de science
fiction toute la science fiction télé
réalité et
c'est la première révolution
industrielle à la paix en afrique le
participé à laquelle l'afrique doivent
accepter et à la haye la fille participe
déjà il faut les dits de première
révolution industrielle
l'afrique était absent en fait c'est
l'une des raisons de son développement
l'une des raisons fondamentales des
principales et qui nous fait qu'on n'a
jamais participé à l'évolution
industrielle dans les principales
langues et capteur est juste un
consommateur des produits de cette
évolution est donc aujourd'hui la
révolution digitale la siècle maxxi la
plupart c'est pourquoi parce que les
conditions d'accessibilité de façon
digitale se sont allégées il n'y a qu'à
frapper clé qui permet d'alléger ses
solutions de la société dépasse
résultats de premiers pas peur ce pied
et à leurs alliés dans l'ex ce soit en
lui n'est pas les petits sont amoindries
aujourd'hui pour être acteur de la
révolution digitale
on n'a plus besoin d'investir
d'importants capitaux de nous en france
youtube ou imprimantes et moi même qu'il
vous parle je suis vieux je suis
entrepreneur des visiteurs avec des amis
nous avons pu développer une plateforme
centre en moyens
donc je suis un fils ou un navet digital
billy et l'avion de la sidérurgie il
et c'est là quelques années et
aujourd'hui nous pouvons être
l'industriel digital le dessin papier
c'est notre outil un outil qu'on appelle
un point informatique des lumières qui
permet enfin de ses invités la
technologie deux nuls vierges qui permet
de de saint tite la technologie de
passionnés à la démence en
infrastructures on n'a plus besoin
d'aller louer des entrepôts d'investir
beaucoup de capitaux dans des serveurs
informatiques et avec le coude un fruit
très sage il est au pouvoir documenter
son processus avec le club poutine on a
certes tout de suite à un vivier
d'infrastructures et le troisième
facteur c'est la démocratisation du
savoir il faut les dire de savoir est
devenu aujourd'hui disponibles et savoir
par tous de savoir mondiale s'organise
avec les fennecs
aujourd'hui au tour de google on a assez
haut pour les universités prestigieuses
des avoirs hec qu'il offre à travers et
nf et moi qui vous parle je n'ai jamais
suivi de cours dans le digital
tout ce que nous savons du digital nous
l'avons et que quand un facteur ce sont
les téléphonie mobile la téléphonie
mobile qui sont en fait devenus un des
diffusions du cernil jeetah le taux de
pénétration de téléphonie mobile est
très important aujourd'hui on a pu
admirer et 100% donc on a pu des
prostituées
ce qu'ils vont essayer digital les
freins si tu es déjà là il faut
souscrire et pour tous les quatre
facteurs qui permettent en fait pas
l'affairé de participer à la révolution
digitale la fille d'alain bashung
c'était quand même pas perdu et la
révolution digitale
l'afrique est en pleine mutation
démographique à 100 millions d'africains
d'aujourd'hui sont de l'issue de la
classe moyenne qui l'aurait fait sans
les lions d'afrique et pour nombre de
pièces d'ici 2050 80 types qui sont de
la race des routeurs la pression
démographique moyenne progressant de la
free ainsi un écrivain c'est la qualité
issus d'au moins 2100 le marché la
machine qui ajuste juste la netteté
était intacte en disqualifiant de
l'arctique
le cerveau est donc mort la fille est
dans une partie inédite l'afrique à une
continuité pour sortir enfin d'une
structure mais pour cela la fête bat j
il faut être créatif nous devons mener
des actions fort pouvoir jouer la toile
dans ce changement digital est la
première action c'est d'initier toute
cette jeunesse d'afrique et au langage
de machines il faut qu'on apprenne à
blâmer il faut vivre mais nos systèmes
éducatifs
nous vivons dans un monde de machines ne
pouvons pas ne pas savoir communiquer
avec leurs machines
nous ce qu'on appelle donc à mes côtés
la deuxième action soit amené c'est leur
emploi et de formation en
entrepreneuriat
n'oublions pas on passe d'une révolution
mais la finalité économique
il faut qu'on apprenne à maîtriser le
business model de cette révolution
il faut qu'on ait des investisseurs
africains développer en afrique et les
ingénieurs africaine qu'ils puissent
évoluer dans le bal dans le paradigme en
fin de cette évolution pour une économie
durable qui valent franchit donc la vie
n'a rien et consorts des développements
et finalement il faut pendant ligue
l'âge la stratégie de nos pays arabes et
au nouvel an sur la rive en entendant sa
fille de développement de louper sous la
révolution digitale
pourquoi parce que nous avons fait la
chose la révolution digitale en fait en
est réalisée en fin d hectares avec la
révolution digitale notre état pétanque
l'été 2006 l'europe c'est le gars est
tué dix ans et donc on a une
on ne doit pas la rater et si nous
arrivons à opérer tous ces changements à
faire à changer de paradigme de paiement
effectué révolution digitale
on pourrait s'imaginer faire emploi se
conclure et de fibres digital nous
allons avoir notre vie au quotidien qui
va être impactée dans tous les domaines
d'un domaine de l'habitation
on va avoir des soucis au dos tandis que
man city jeudi là il ya une vraie
demande t elle à nouveau logis qui
permet avec les téléphones de commandes
est en fait toutes les énergies tout ce
qui est de la maison l'électricité les
dames la sécurité on va avoir des
impacts aussi dans les films tech
je disais tout à l'heure j'étais dans le
déni du digital c'est dans le film fait
que nous nous avons développé notre mot
d'ordre tous les services financiers
dans ce tour un parti il peut avoir des
répercussions dans les énergies
renouvelables
on a une chance afin de reconstruire
notre peau système environnemental ou
des énergies propres
avec le digital il y avait aussi sur les
applications du type dans plusieurs
domaines les plus récents sont survenus
pendant la fête on a utilisé d'être
numériquement dans des stands et ça a
été très régulier il y en à nos
technologies qui est là la santé il aura
aussi tous les types d'industries à 20
piges et du divertissement qui va se
passer à travers le téléphone c'est tout
un choc en activité nous devons explorer
parce que n'oubliez pas fils nous
faisons la révolution digitale le
souverain continue à développer quand on
a un peu loupé causera beaucoup de
graviers et au divertissement et sa part
à ces français avec les défunts dans une
vie constitutionnelle
le phénomène est des états unis nous
apprécions la tarification et du péage
de aussi l'intelligence artificielle qui
en hiver est une révolution dans la
révolution
il faut savoir que la bataille en direct
la mairie et la chine ne devons pas
rester à la traîne et d'encore la fri
imaginait tous auteurs de l'utilisation
c'est un peu comme alice au pays des
merveilles
cette fois ci verrait on est pénible
réalité la fri le futur du monde et en
afrique ça c'est pas moi ce qu'il est
dit
même si je ne suis pas l'abruti nous
devons à ces petits ou de grands buffets
fasse aimer les vélodi la fuite
la jouer un rôle leader dans la
formation
albert einstein disait que l'imagination
est plus important que les savants nous
avons pour finir monde où l'imagination
et le rêve sont devenus des ressources à
part entière mais jusqu'à aujourd'hui je
crois que le raid est gratuit donc les
chefs et les chefs nous devons réussir
nous devons beaucoup rêver et continuer
de rêver parce que c'est gratuit
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]